so you've played a lot of intellects
over your career I want to put you on
the spot who's smarter tolki nor Hank
McCoy that's different because they're
very they're Tolkien's more imaginative
and Hank McCoy is more scientifically
smart I would say you know he's he's
creative in like that element that's a
nice balanced answer yeah very different
so speaking of balanced you are playing
a romantic lead a creator god and a war
hero over the course of this movie was
it difficult for you to balance the
different personas in the three
storylines I don't think so it's kind of
different elements of of his life
essentially and that's what was
wonderful about this story learning
about you know him becoming an orphan
but then finding love and the
friendships that he developed it gave
him that safe place to create and then
also his experiences during the war and
I think that's the that's the great
thing about playing him as this
character is you get to see these
different elements of what made him the
man and the creative genius that he is
and yeah I guess with any character you
never play them essentially as as one
thing because people are always
different day to day in different
scenarios so you just kind of switch in
to what's happening at that time were
you familiar with the Beren and lúthien
inspiration before you took this I
wasn't know that was something that I
learned and then obviously was it was I
was like okay this is incredible that
this is essentially an allegory for his
love and his relationship with Edith and
finding out all those things and then
we're very lucky to get Lily Collins to
play that character who just brings
Edith to life in an incredible way and
and their relationships very cheeky and
small and funny you can see completely
why these people would have spent their
whole lives together and you get to play
out a scene that is very legendary in
the books but we've never seen in any of
the adapted material with the the dance
where she's dancing yeah yeah yeah well
that's completely what inspired the
forest ants in the book so it's kind of
one of those brilliant things where it
was kind of it was forever I think I
think there was like told Lily like okay
now do elven dancing like don't really
know exactly what that was but it's kind
of this lovely ethereal moment I suppose
you probably had the easier half of that
scene it definitely had these
I got to lay there and be like yeah do
the Elven dancing if I had been told to
the oven I would have done almost more
of a jig oh yeah the scene where you are
lying in the trench and you have the
fever how many days did you shoot that
for the whole trench sequence or the war
part of the element of the movie took
two weeks to film that's really
incredible was it as cold as it looked
it was free it was so cold I remember
like there's one moment where I'm in a
bomb a bomb crater mm-hmm surrounded by
bodies and there's there's water at the
bottom and and the kind of wonderful
thing that don't make him up with this
was a lot of time in World War one you
don't see color and you realize that the
color of the gases and the color of the
water with the chemicals in the blood a
little it seeped into it so I mean an
amazing set to be on but I do remember
that morning they were like breaking the
ice the water and taking the ice out so
I could get it then lay in it for a few
hours until I think that i think the set
doctor like eventually was like took my
temperature was like we've gotta get him
to warm up a little bit because he'd my
he's he's pretty chilly Tommy also said
that when you were shooting back stage
of the Opera it was really cold so did
you ever get to be warm making this
movie there were some nice scenes inside
where we got a war like in cozy like tea
shops and things like that where I was
like oh this is nice but that's the nice
thing about playing this character again
it's like the contrast of all the things
that um built this man and and and what
he created the final question that I
have that I like to ask everyone is
what's a moment or scene that you want
people to look out for when they see
this movie a moment I've seen the Grand
Cafe scene with liliane kind of first
time you meet them as adults and and
kind of cements their relationship
that's a scene that I loved playing and
also kind of rare to have a scene that
long in any movie though and that was
something doing they was very protective
of so that's a that was a great scene
backstage at the Opera and then there's
a scene later on in the movie with a
mrs. Smith one of one of Tolkien's
friend's mother who I just yet thought
was a really beautifully written scene
great thank you so much thank you
you